hello my name is kiemann palau i am half
dinet
and half tongan my name is marianne
buggs i'm an enrolled member of the
caddo tribe
and i'm also cheyenne arapahoe i'm
brandi lewis and i'm a member of the
choctaw nation of oklahoma hi my name is
silas cleveland i'm an eastern shoshone
native american from the wind river
indian reservation here in wyoming
today i'm going to be answering your
questions about native americans
why do people call native americans
indians well
that's because christopher columbus was
lost if you don't know who he is
that's probably a good thing he thought
he was in
india and so he called the people that
he encountered
indians i'm not indian i'm not from
india
so don't call me indian please thank you
two indigenous
tribes still exist yes absolutely there
are plenty of tribes out there still
today however there are
many that are not there are over 500
unique and different tribes in the
united states
but did you know there are over 300
tribes that are not yet
federally recognized that is over 800
tribes
on turtle island or what is now the
continental us
that are here each one has their own
language
each one has their own customs i look
forward to a time when everybody
understands
what being native american means what do
native americans
prefer to be called there are a couple
of answers to this
because every native person is going to
have a different response
for myself personally i grew up being
called american indian
i think it's an individual choice not
everybody not everybody who's native
american has the same answer
i prefer native american i have a dear
friends that
they don't like being called indian
indian to me you're probably from india
i like to be referred to as being
choctaw
that's what i am i'm a member of the
choctaw nation and i'm a choctaw woman
there's so many terms aboriginal first
nations
native american native indigenous it's a
preference
i know that i personally like to be
called indigenous
i think it's the best term to describe
me and my ancestors
as the original people of this land what
do native americans
believe in well if i was joking i would
say fry bread but um
i think that you're referring to like a
spiritual
spiritual beliefs and that's that's
going to be very tried to try
individual individual in general we
believe that we
are responsible for this land that we
were
placed in this country
to take care of it i personally have
feel a deep connection to this land
and all the creatures and
um things that are on it because of
colonization forced conversion on my
people
we were not allowed to practice our way
of life we were not allowed to speak our
language
it was deemed evil savage
not of god and if we were to do so
we were either beaten whipped or killed
so my people had to conform we had to
adapt
in order to survive which is sad and
over time
that religion was instilled you have
natives that are
catholic you have natives that are
christian and you have natives that are
neither
that are reconnecting trying to
backtrack
and learn about our way of life
about our beliefs before they were
taken from us is native american and
ethnicity
yes i would say so although we speak
different languages
and we're not all the same we have that
shared
appreciation and thankfulness for
everything that surrounds us
i believe that it is an ethnicity i
believe that it is a culture
native americans have a rich
and vibrant and wonderful culture no
matter what tribe they are
do native americans celebrate
thanksgiving and i think that's
you know a preference that native people
can make for themselves i celebrate
thanksgiving
because that's how i was raised i think
it's a time
in general just to be thankful about the
life that we have here
but there are many native americans who
do not celebrate it i like the idea of
thanksgiving
i'm all for being thankful giving back
and being with friends and family
however that is romanticized
thanksgiving is much much more than that
it is a deep-rooted pain and hurt
and story of colonization
massacre lies so
for me and my family it is a day of
mourning
my family we we don't always do the
typical
quintessential thanksgiving dinner i
actually try to do some traditional
dishes
and incorporate those in our meals and
use it as a time for education so to me
it's still
gathering with family definitely not
forgetting keeping the ancestors in mind
always thinking about that thinking
about what they had to go through
what is the reservation it's kind of a
sad word really when i think about
reservation
a reservation is an area that native
americans were technically given which
i mean they were our lands to begin with
the government the united states were
greedy
and lustful for oil property and gold
and we were in the way so they forced us
to relocate onto tiny patches of land so
far
from what was home for us hoping that we
would slowly die off
today there are many reservations where
there
is no running water where the
population is almost entirely in poverty
and
where sickness and other things exist
that cause harm to our people the
reservation
system in america is a tragedy
actually while there is a rich
culture and people it is a stark
reminder
of how this country has mistreated
the native american population i hope
that we continue to make strides
in improving the reservation system and
i invite
everybody to look up or google
native american reservations near me and
visit one
or find out more about one well i really
enjoyed these questions
i'm happy that people are still googling
us
people are still curious i think i would
say
uh to non-native people spend more time
asking questions and listening i
welcome each and every opportunity that
comes along to speak
about my people because i'm very proud
of who i am
and what my people represent i hope you
learned something new today i hope i
answered some of your questions
i'd like to give a shout out to the wind
river indian reservation to the eastern
shoshone my tribe
and the northern arapaho over here too
i love you all and have a blessed day
you